well into the 80s corporate CEOs were
cigarette smoking suit wearing gentlemen
who maybe played some golf on the
weekends the CEOs of today are not only
Rich they are ripped and I'm not just
talking about Jeff Bezos who famously
went from looking like this to looking
like this I'm talking about so many
high-profile CEOs Mark Zuckerberg
telegram executive Pavel durov record
executive Scooter Braun businessman
Strauss zelnick who posed in purple
spandex high-end real estate broker
Jason abenheim The Wall Street Journal
calls it the latest power move for
middle-aged men looking like an ad for
protein powder
so why is there suddenly such a focus on
getting fit
well when selfies and social media are
the norm there is a greater awareness of
Public Image
Zuckerberg showed off his punches and
kicks on Instagram as he trained with a
professional MMA fighter he says he fell
in love with mixed martial arts during
the pandemic
the shift to remote work meant people
suddenly found themselves locked indoors
with a lot more time on their hands
while that could also mean putting on
the pandemic pounds those with money in
a team behind them took advantage of the
time to focus on Fitness
but getting ripped is not only the
result of the pandemic it's a turning of
the tables of sorts men used to be
judged by their shoes and their watch so
long as they were Rich they could slack
off when it came to their physical
appearance but that's not really true
anymore especially when women began to
wield financial success when the
workplace doors started to open for them
in the 60s and 70s female Executives
have long known the importance of
appearance and that includes staying
physically fit and now the beauty
standard has fallen on men it's almost
unacceptable to be fat and flabby when
Elon Musk soaked up the sun on a
friend's yacht in the summer he got a
lot of body shaming for the way he
looked some fun in the mikuno sun may
have been a rarity for the richest
person in the world his lack of a tan
could mean he's hard at work inside
Tesla's factories by the way you may
recall musk took a jab at Bill Gates by
tweeting a photo of the Microsoft
founder side by side with a pregnant man
emoji musk acknowledged on the podcast
full send that he needs to exercise more
I gotta work out and be in better shape
you know so
um we need you around uh thanks I
actually don't really like working on it
but um I gotta do it he says he'll try
to work out for at least 20 minutes as
soon as he wakes up instead of
immediately looking at his phone
there is perhaps another deeper reason
for CEOs to go from looking like nerds
to looking like Thor these days exercise
also releases brain chemicals that
improve your memory concentration and
mental sharpness giving you a major
advantage in the workplace in the way
pro athletes prepare for competition
running a company is extremely
competitive mentally and physically
demanding with long days that stretch
into nights and weekends musk famously
worked 120 hours a week or 17 hours a
day during his company's most trying
times some CEOs believe they wouldn't be
where they are today without staying in
shape
despite his busy schedule running virgin
group Richard Branson finds time to
exercise every day when I wake up in the
morning I normally go and play a very
hard game of tennis really early about
six in the morning with somebody who's a
lot better than me
um a pro and then I might go for a quick
height stuff I live on an island so I'm
lucky you know I'll then
um go into the gym with with somebody
and maybe do 40 minutes of weight
lifting one day and then the next day I
will then run or ride bikes or or
whatever the 72 year old swears by the
fact that Fitness has been the key to
his success seeing in an interview I
definitely can achieve twice as much in
a day by keeping fit
Mark Cuban's proudest exercise moment is
when he bench pressed 300 pounds and
also when the Dallas Mavericks owner
dunked a basketball for the first time
at the age of 37. apparently a CEO's
Fitness level does affect their bottom
line in a decade-long study of 1500
Executives the University of cologne
found in 2015 that a CEO's physical
fitness was associated with higher firm
profitability and higher merger and
acquisition announcement returns so a
healthy leader makes the company more
money for both themselves and for their
shareholders allowing the wealthy CEO to
splurge on Yachts this one is reportedly
bezos's property and investing in their
own health even more
being healthy so you feel better and
perform your best should be top of mind
for everyone not only those with
billions of dollars getting good sleep
is incredibly important for your health
that's why I trust magnesium
breakthrough bye bye optimizers ever
since I've been taking magnesium
breakthrough since the start of this
year I felt a lot better it's made me
more relaxed my sleep is so much better
which is super helpful when I work on
videos like these that demand a lot of
my attention what makes magnesium
breakthrough Stand Out is that there are
no synthetic ingredients all of the
ingredients are naturally derived when
you get all seven critical forms of
magnesium as you do with magnesium
breakthrough your body gets a serious
upgrade so you can feel better
throughout your day if you head to
magnesium breakthrough.com
newsthink you'll save an extra 10 my
custom link is in my description and pin
comment and don't forget to use my promo
code newsthink 10 at checkout thanks for
watching for newsthink I'm Cindy Palm
[Music]